- The Redwood Forest is
a very special place.
It's the darkest forest on Earth.
The trees are so tall, they
create their own shadows,
and in those shadows,
there are a lot of secrets.
(gentle music)
My name is Dave Kuty. I'm a docent here
at Henry Cowell Redwoods State Park.
I consider myself kind
of a volunteer naturalist
and redwood researcher.
Before coming to Henry Cowell,
I was a engineer in Silicon Valley.
But, I just love the redwoods.
I've always been an
outdoor kind of person.
I've been coming here for 40 years.
I come so often now I
swear I could almost tell
when a single branch fell.
These are the coastal
redwood, Sequoia sempervirens.
It is the tallest tree
on Earth by species.
Their wood is very, very interesting.
It's red in color.
It's very complex, genetically,
and you can have some that
are not like all the others.
Albino redwoods have been
called ghosts of the forest.
We have found 13 albinos in this park.
There are not very many,
not when you consider
there's two million
redwood trees out there.
I really know albinos.
I know where they all are, and
I continue to look for more.
Albino redwoods have a
very, very soft nature.
They aren't as structurally
sound as a normal redwood,
and we keep trying to
understand why they form here.
When we first started
looking at these things
we said, "OK, they're
genetically different."
But it could be contamination.
So, we have done some testing.
Found that these guys
actually collect more nickel
than these guys.
Nickel would normally kill chlorophyll,
but the albino redwood
doesn't have any chlorophyll,
so it doesn't hurt it at all.
So, where's the source of nickel?
Well, we're on a railroad.
Some researchers think
it is acting like a liver
filtering out the toxic components
protecting the rest of the forest.
When I first started here,
I started telling everybody
where they were, and then
I started finding pieces
of albino redwood on the ground.
People would go and touch and fold and
break off pieces, and I realized
that I couldn't do that.
I could not be open with people
because they were gonna
go in and destroy it.
So, their location has been kept secret.
Redwoods are a treasure of the Earth.
They really are.
And the more you study
them, the more you realize
how unique they are and
how adaptable they are.
Part of the fascination
of the redwood forest
is its diversity.
I continue to be fascinated by what I see.
(gentle music)